hello how is it to be an electro mejía
with your brief information today is
wednesday april 28th the
technology convention announces that it will return
to las vegas next year the event
will be in person and with access to
digital platforms so that
people around  the world
can also enjoy it the announcement was made
this morning if it will take place
from january 5 to 8
there will be a vaccination clinic or at the
javi war recreation center east of the
valley the event will be from 4 to 8 pm then
tomorrow there will be  another clinic inside the
66 retirement center near management
and it will be this saturday the
va a price community center near lake mi isla
will also be offering vaccinations from
half past nine in the morning until three in the
afternoon to schedule an appointment visit the
page  from the southern nevada health district
families who need help with
newborn baby resources
can attend the free diaper fair
at gender today
is  the event will be at the
alleviation recreation center located near boulder
highway and 'mater opened this will be drive-
thru and will start at 10
am you must register in
advance on the babys bounty
point page or heretic
now check out the weather forecast
winds  from the north with
clear skies for this wednesday temperatures
warmer in the 80s and the maximums will
warm up to 90 degrees
starting tomorrow and close to the records this
weekend have a nice day I am
hector mejía and this was your brief
information on  dyspnea or in Spanish
[Music]